let's go next to um audrey in georgia
audrey and georgia you're on the air oh
hi
um i didn't expect to be called um
uh did you see recently about the
accidental
shooting involving a uh a woman who
meant to uh
tase a woman a a man that um
was being arrested yes we covered that
earlier this week
all right i wanted to ask your opinion
on something uh
what do you think should should be the
outcome for the police officer in this
situation do you think she should be
charged with manslaughter do you think
they should uh
simply bar her from police service and
let her off the hook
what do you think it's not for me to say
she has been charged with second-degree
manslaughter i believe i
i just read uh yes yes yeah and so it's
it's going to be up to a court to decide
that
my opinion about what the outcome would
be
was that she is not going to see a
guilty
criminal verdict in a court of law my
prediction was
on the criminal side it will probably
plead out and there will be a big
financial
settlement civilly that's my prediction
but i think that now that the second
degree manslaughter charges come forward
we we just have to let it you know it uh
i don't have
all of the evidence i've seen the video
i've seen commentary it
you know we need to go through the the
process
yeah um i was talking about somebody
else earlier i i think most people can
agree that this
this was you know an accident it's just
um
now the thing about calling it an
accident i think that there's a better
way to say it
her intention did not appear to be to
shoot
the victim yeah whether we say that
that's an
accident or we say this is negligence by
someone
whose job is supposed to be to know do
you have your taser or your gun in your
hand
we're talking about the same thing but
the implication of the words we use is
very different so for me you know when
we say
it was an accident versus we say it was
a negligent action by an officer
it's different and that's why i'm
careful about using that word
oh yeah of course uh thank you for
correcting me on that
um but what i'm interested in
is like uh the further action that
should be taken to prevent these things
from happening in the future
yeah so um as uh we were talking about
this yesterday
in in this server and somebody pointed
out that the
service weapons that they use in the
minnesota police force the taser that
they specifically use
made by axon is extremely similar
in shape in color and in weight to their
service pistol
and um it doesn't surprise me learning
that
that some and i uh something like this
would happen
well you know there's another asp let me
ask about another aspect maybe you know
this audrey maybe you don't
is it accurate that officers carry
their gun and taser on their
it's like the gun is always on one side
dominant versus non-dominant and the
taser is always on the opposite
um and i saw an interesting analysis of
this yeah um
i obviously i'm not a psychologist so i
don't i don't know if this is true or
not okay but
an analysis from a police psychologist
who had said that under stressful
situations sometimes your motor cortex
can
um can do the opposite action of what
you were actually commanding it to do
so that there could be a psychological
explanation for this
um i don't know the validity of that
yeah that i don't know about it
because it's coming from a police
psychologist right yeah no that
that i don't know about either listen i
think that i am very comfortable having
watched the video
and saying the officer did not
intend to shoot the victim but that to
me
does not tell me what i need to know in
order to determine
what should happen in a court of law and
that's what the system is now going to
have to adjudicate
yeah personally i think she should be
um convicted of manslaughter simply for
the fact
that it imagined that there was
this was a minority and in this exact
same situation i believe that they would
be
convicted of manslaughter you're saying
a minority officer
uh yeah in a similar situation
okay i think that they would likely in a
court of law not be seen as
fairly as a white more
privileged police officer got it i don't
think that it would be fair
for them to get charged and convicted
and for somebody else not to okay very
good audrey i appreciate it
all right thank you very much all right
uh let's see who else we can
we can hear from today uh
how about we speak to um
[Music]
let's go to tony from california
tony from california you're on the air
uh hello hello oh yeah i was in class
sorry um
i have a question uh regarding joe
manchin sure uh last weekend when he was
talking about um
uh when he said that uh what was it um
he will not vote to eliminate or reform
the filibuster
right or uh we can sorry
yep and um i have mixed thoughts about
what he meant by weekend
okay such as um
maybe by um nuking the filibuster for
certain
types of legislation okay or just for
any type of
uh reform so i'm just wondering what you
think
about that i think at this point it's
very clear that
uh joe manchin is not willing to do
anything at all to change the
filibusters is the way i'm interpreting
it
uh so for me i don't even find it
necessary to analyze
what would be on one side of the line
and on the other side of the line
i'm not getting the impression he's
willing to do anything
okay do you disagree
um i don't know i i really don't know um
i mean i've only been getting into
politics like
last year yeah so i i really don't know
anything i mean listen i get the
impression that at this point joe
manchin
knows that he has the potential to have
a lot of negotiating power
by being the guy that might keep uh joe
biden from getting 50 votes and keep him
at 49.
i think he knows that i think he's
enjoying it and i think that uh
everything i hear from him including
recently saying the january 6 riots made
him
realize the importance of bipartisanship
almost like he's allowing the hostage
takers to to change his mind
um i'm very concerned by what i'm
hearing from from joe manchin i can't
imagine him being an ally
on any of the the tough things on the
easy things sure he'll vote with
democrats but i'm very worried about
mansion
yeah thank you my pleasure uh all right
thanks everybody who called in
we are going to go to a break we will
take calls again very soon and as always
i'm uh sorry i was not able to get to
everybody